le secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken s'est rendu à ramallah
aujourd'hui où il a rencontré le chef de
l'autorité palestinienne mahmoud abbas
au quatrième jour de la trêve au proche
orient le chef de la diplomatie
américaine s'est entretenu avec les
différents chefs d'état israélien et
palestinien l'occasion d'apporter son
soutien aux deux parties avant
d'annoncer des mesures d' aide au peuple
palestinien dont notamment un apport de
75 millions de dollars pour la
reconstruction de gaza
au final il est possible de reprendre
les efforts pour parvenir à une solution
à deux états que nous continuons de
considérer comme la seule façon
d'assurer le futur d'israël en tant
qu'etat juif et démocratique
et bien sûr de donner aux palestiniens
l'état auquel ils ont comme je l'aï dit
au premier ministre netanyahu et au
président abbas les états unis veulent
avancer sur la réouverture du consulat à
jérusalem
c'est une façon importante pour notre
pays de s'engager et d'apporter son
soutien au peuple palestinien
j'ai informé le président abbas et avant
cela le premier ministre netanyahu que
les états unis vont informer le congrès
de notre intention de fournir 75
millions de dollars dette supplémentaire
au développement et à l'économie des
palestiniens en 2021 des annonces qui
ont été les bienvenues auprès des
palestiniens les précisions sur place à
ramallah de mohamed hamayel journaliste
indépendant pour toulouse jean mimi
constaté beaucoup de palestiniens venant
d un consulat il propose des services
nécessaires pour les palestiniens et ils
sont donc atteint 8,7 prêteurs pouvait
faire la reconstruction des relations
avec les états unis
c'est d'autant plus important pour
certains
air austral car pendant l'ère trump
beaucoup de palestiniens n'ont pas pu
avoir accès aux services du consulat
après sa fermeture à jérusalem pour
beaucoup de personnes c'est un progrès
vers une amélioration des relations
entre palestine et états unis